this is dedicated to all the people who
are visionary enough to recognize the
enormous opportunities we've been given
in this new digital age and who are
brave enough to demand and seek out
happiness not only in their life but
also in their work what's that blog
about to go into the studio actually I'm
in the studio about to record the audio
book for crushing it but excited that
was out to 4 o'clock in the morning the
Superbowl so I'm gonna kick him out
because he's not allowed in here but
here we go it took all those years for
it to happen
but now I feel like I'm finally at a
place where I want it to be it's crazy
that this is where it is but I love it
if you don't care enough to induce
others to rave about you all you're
doing is holding a spot for someone who
really does care the one who will waltz
in and displace you this book features
entrepreneurs at all levels of financial
success and all stages of influence but
those currently at the pinnacle of both
shared three characteristics a
commitment to service a desire to
provide value a love of teaching if your
nature is that at least 51% altruistic
and only 49% selfish we have a real shot
of breaking out because the vast
majority of people are 70 to 99 percent
selfish oh right click and and it's very
simple if global and local dynamics with
digital aren't working there's nuances
and everybody thinks that they're
solving it by having all these offices
which creates even more cooks in the
kitchens not less by doing one centric
strategic base partner who also over
over indexes and these three pillars of
being you know peacemakers being deep
practitioners having willingness
allocate heavy hours to engagement and
speed of production and cost now you got
something so just finished up the audio
book here in Minnesota and which is fun
we're kind of thing and now we're here
at the Mall of America and about to go
to radio bro where the media is with
some of our athletes and obviously
people want to know what I'll have to do
with our sports so quite a surprise this
is the great Gary Vee will now sit down
with us Gary what's up my man life is
good
other than the fact that I've seen way
too many Patriot Jersey City
my lender Carson shops [ __ ] hate the
Patriots so I'm struggling with that but
other than that life is tremendous Gary
so much of your videos
we have
right now obviously we're too young
dross at broadcasters ourselves what
would be the number one piece of advice
that you would give
reverse-engineered the attention that
comes native to you
aka there's so much more attention on
Facebook podcasts YouTube Instagram snap
than people realize and the fact of
mentally if I decided to become the
biggest sports announcer over you know
tomorrow I really think in four years
I'm in the conversation and it's because
I have passion for it I acknowledge for
it but most importantly I understand
distribution of it so everybody who's
listening if you want to do something if
you want to be the guy that knows more
about the Lions than anybody on earth or
if you want to be the person that is the
foremost experts on middle relievers you
can actually do that you know and I'm
stunned by people not understanding how
much of a player we should report at bar
school is in just seven to ten years
based on this thesis all of you [ __ ]
understand this you either are not
willing to put in the work to get there
or to you actually don't realize that
you're sitting on disproportionate
knowledge thanks guys
yummy and we're off to a good start 18
months in we're getting some real
players it is the four of my like
existence Matt was part of the company
when we bought a small firm to get into
the business so our relationship you
know Jackson Robert it's all very
special but like from day zero for me
that's been a part of that family and I
think
it is very interesting for me to
actually care about a Broncos game now
because you care about the person you
have a lot of thoughts about business
and and all the things they're gonna be
happening off the field that we can
control as agents and agencies much more
than what can happen on the field we
think that there's a huge arbitrage to
be had there's a lot being left on the
field and you know after a bunch of
homework and both on who they were and
what we thought they could do Braxton
came to the top of the list and the
conversation started the punch line is
outside of a couple of sporting goods
companies and a couple of you know
besides football cards and sneakers
these kids are not making real economics
off the field meanwhile in my other life
I'm representing 15 year old teenagers
on musically making seven hundred
thousand dollars a year and marketing
and so they can build much bigger
audiences and and so it's getting to
know them not making them become garyvee
and do it like me and vlog all day and
do all this and be crazy know who are
you and where and where can you go so
it's reverse engineering
if you've been making excuses you'll be
exposed at which point you can decide to
stop [ __ ] around and achieve what you
set out to achieve or admit that your
version of crushing it looks a little
different than you'd originally thought
I cannot I know this I've read so many
darks with this guy it is so good
[Applause]
this is a real college friend of mine
thank you man yeah yeah
hey man man how are you good I know I
know he's my brother AJ
Tyler and babban hey great to meet you
guys it's a pleasure man I'm glad to
finally see this book is for two
audiences the first is for people who
know to the depths of their souls that
they are born to build something great
natural born entrepreneurs should find
all the information they need to improve
the current efforts or start making
plans of their own not just the young
not just the tech oriented not just
professionals and establish careers or
those looking to renew themselves
because they've outgrown their
industries or worse their industry is
striking
[Music]
[Music]